[Music]
we have a problem you're trying to tell
me the Legion of Doom here's the sphere
of destiny to rewrite reality editor
oldest three not yes just get it
watching your [ __ ] toilet something
you're not a janitor we should have
killed them all the represent means are
our hapless DC's legends of tomorrow all
new Tuesday 9/8 central on the CW
hey youtubers it's Charlie we got to
talk about how the reverse-flash just
became the god of the DC Universe we
were just talking about musikmeister on
the flash being crazy Opie last night he
vanishes like mr. Mitzvah spit lick and
it's completely nuts the way they
explain it on legends of tomorrow makes
way more sense so there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway a reverse flash
ring giveaway we should say all you to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so we'll explain
what's going on and where I think
they're taking the season spinning into
season three it's already been renewed
for season three so you always wonder
what's going to happen to the villains
at the end of the season so I'll try to
explain that - quick recap from the last
episode there are a couple big Easter
eggs they did that jr. are talking
episodes they go back in time to World
War 1 to find the blood of Christ that
will enable them to destroy the spear
everything goes sideways predictably
because they'd already released the
title for this episode doom world and it
wasn't even close to being the last
episode so it's like well of course the
Legion is going to get the spear and
change reality it would have been
terrible if they didn't give that to
them it was like the whole point of
their arc this season was in bringing
about the thing that they wanted most in
making that somewhat compelling like you
have the reverse-flash that wants to fix
his time aberration so the black flash
will stop coming for him so he just
wants to live and get rid of Barry Allen
on the side I'll talk about that in a
second because the Darth Vader helmet
from Legion of Doom is now STAR Labs
this is so crazy
Marc Guggenheim tweeted this picture out
and it made me so happy but I had to
check because the background didn't look
exactly like STAR Labs in Central City
like we see it on the flash like it
looks like a slightly different place
but then you look at Rey who's wearing
STAR Labs uniform he basically cleans
the toilets inside STAR Labs so it seems
like one of the things that the
reverse-flash gave back to himself was
the STAR Labs from season 1 because he
said he missed that so much so we'll
talk about the logic of that in a second
but they went back they met with JRR
tolkien so there were a whole bunch of
Lord of the Rings Easter eggs we have to
take the powerful artifact and destroy
it
in the heart of Hell itself so they're
basically teasing the plot of Lord of
the Rings they joke about him liking
really long stories because Lord of the
Rings is a really long book story they
even did fire reveals the secret like
fire reveals the secret of the Ring of
Power fire reveals the secret of the
spear of destiny
a really big thing is they brought back
Captain Cold he's alive but he's from a
previous point in the timeline from
before season 1 of legends of tomorrow
so in the future he still dies but they
brought a past version of him back so
that explains how he's still super evil
he still has a strong connection to Mick
he gets Mick to steal the spear and give
it to them so happy the Captain Cold is
alive and well again and evil as usual
you see the value in bringing him back
to they can go use him on the flash it
was so hard to do that this past season
I think they just wanted to give him a
break for a little while where maybe it
has something to do with him filming
that Prison Break series either way they
probably just wanted to spend more time
focusing on the heatwave character he
was kind of under served during the
first season season two heatwave is a
light years better than season 1
heatwave but I do kind of like the way
they're sort of resetting things back to
their original States so he wave captain
colds teaming up again in the future
hopefully we'll see Captain Cold alive
fighting Barry Allen during season 4 of
the flash I would really love it if he
became one of the big bads but I don't
think that's going to happen if the
Rogues becomes a big bad those cycles of
membership just a little bit it would
have to be more of a Legion of Doom
situation where you have an ensemble
villain cast but I don't know if they're
going to go in that direction it's just
one of the big possibilities but by this
trailer we see that the Legion has
changed reality so all of the legends
don't remember the previous timeline
Mick does and he's the one that goes
around telling them look everything's
change I made a huge mistake we need to
change it back so most of the fun of
this episode is just going to be seeing
all the changes and what everybody's
like in this darkest timeline version
vixen and Sarah or Evil Charlie's Angels
working for damian darhk-- reverse-flash
is now head of STAR Labs again he has
Martin Stein in Jack's working for him
and Ray who's cleaning the toilets but
Jackson Martin Stein looks like they're
building some evil device for
reverse-flash so you do wonder if they
have all these STAR Labs badges on where
the flash characters did he already get
rid of Barry Allen but if you're
wondering how they can pull this off
like if reverse flash really did change
everything and give himself his old life
back and get rid of Barry Allen what's
happened to him and why wouldn't they
address that on the flash TV show we
don't really know how they're going to
address it in the episode but think
about it this way if reverse flash we're
able to array
Barry Allen from existence that he
wouldn't be around to complain about it
so what I'll assume is if we don't see
everybody from the flash in the episode
which I'm not expecting is that they'll
just be often some other Wayne working
because it sounded like he really likes
Cisco and Caitlin
so he's changed them the way he's
changed vixen and Sarah but if you're
wondering why the reverse-flash couldn't
have done this without the spear of
destiny Barry Allen needed to become the
flash so that he could eventually become
the flash there was a really cool
version of the origin story that Geoff
Johns retold in the lead up to
flashpoint where you find out how the
reverse flash was a big fan of Barry out
he became a professor of Blache Studies
he studies a Speed Force then
miraculously one day a time capsule
appears in front of him he finds Barry
Allen's old flash costume the flash ring
and uses the traces of the Speed Force
that are left on it to reverse engineer
the accident that gave Barry powers and
gives himself Speed Force powers
becoming the reverse flash
so his origin is forever tied to Barry
Allen that's why he's unable to kill him
in the past he can kill all of his
friends he can make his life miserable
but he has to keep Barry alive so that
he can eventually become reverse flash
the workaround of that is the spear of
destiny because that allows you to break
the laws of the universe you have the
power of God so you can make anything
happen you want you can make everybody
in the universe a speedster if you
really wanted to and I know a lot of you
are asking about Tommy after the last
episode because they had that nice
Easter Egg for Tommy on arrow because ma
Nell's name was Tommy inside the dream
he was the fake version of Merlin's son
the thing that Merlin wants most is to
bring his family back and probably get
his company back too so you have to
imagine that Merlin sort of reset his
life to what it was like at the
beginning of arrow season 1 Tommy was
alive they had a great relationship
maybe his wife is alive again now too
but I don't know if they were able to
get Colin Donald for a guest appearance
so I'm not expecting to actually see
Tommy on the show but just remember that
he has a couple people that are in his
family that he loves really much that
are dead so those are probably the
people that he wanted back same thing
applies for damian darhk-- too because
his family died at the end of his run on
arrow but let me know in the comments
how do you think this is all going to go
down obviously the legends are going to
fix time in some way and destroy the
spear of destiny
but where does that leave the villains
because I think it would be disingenuous
to try and get rid of the reverse-flash
he's too big of a character so somehow
they'll fix the time aberration aspect
so that he can continue to exist but not
be so Opie that he doesn't need the help
of the rest of the Legion anymore so the
whole reason he needed their help this
season was because the black flash was
after him so he couldn't use the Speed
Force as much as he wanted to so what it
sounds like is going to happen is the
Legion of Doom will continue to be a
seeing in season 3 they might cycle the
roster just a little bit and use them in
a slightly different way and there'll be
a different makeup and like they won't
be going after the spear of destiny
again that's sort of a finale
post-credits type twist where the
villains are sitting around with their
tails between their legs like oh we've
been defeated and then all of a sudden
reverse-flash like sticks his hand up it
goes I have an idea gentleman is in
talks about some new artifact or some
new source of power that they go after
that will allow them to try and take
over the world again it's very pinky in
the brain so there's this aspect of
comic-book villainy in comedy so like
they're always going to be defeated by
the heroes but that doesn't mean that
they won't be able to change the world
for the worse
every once in a while too so doom world
rider dies there's a really cool news
you guys may have heard lena luthor on
Supergirl was up to series regular
meaning she's going to be in most of the
episodes in issues kind of supergirls
friend on the show right now but she's a
villain in the comics does that not
remind you of the arc that Deathstroke
got on arrow so he and Oliver were
friends on the island or kind of friends
I guess you could call him that then
eventually over time became a very hated
very good comic book villain you see the
potential there and now they can use her
during the day four-way crossover next
time she could even take Lex Luthor's
place in the Legion of Doom next season
although because she's a series regular
on Supergirl most of her time is going
to be spent on that show but they've
been doing a much better job at doing
smaller crossovers with characters so
Lena Luthor is the de facto Luthor of
the CW universe so she can go on any of
the shows doing any Lex Luthor
storylines that they want her to do just
so much potential there what's going to
happen next is I'll post my arrow video
but that might not post til Thursday
morning just because I've already posted
so many videos in the last two days and
then Deadpool to
is supposed to be casting Michael
Shannon of all people Zod might be cable
in Deadpool too so we'll probably do a
new video for that tomorrow too while
you wait for that next video to post
click here for the next episode of the
flash and click here for last night's
flash Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys in that next video